a breast biopsy usually is performed to
determine if an abnormal area or lump in
your breast is cancerous in this
procedure a tissue sample of the area of
concern is removed so it can be examined
by a pathologist
breast biopsy may involve one of three
main techniques fine needle aspiration
biopsy core needle biopsy or surgical
biopsy your doctor will choose the
technique that best fits your situation
during a fine needle aspiration biopsy
your doctor will insert a needle into
your breast some form of guidance such
as an ultrasound probe will be used to
guide the needle to the correct area
then fluid or a small sample of tissue
will be removed a core needle biopsy is
done to remove several small pieces of
tissue or cores of tissue from the
breast it may be guided using one of
several techniques during a stereotactic
core needle biopsy you will lie facedown
on a table with your breasts inserted
through a hole in the table your doctor
will inject a local anaesthetic to numb
the area then using a digital mammogram
as a guide your doctor will insert a
hollow needle into the area of concern
several small cylinders of tissue will
be removed for examination during an
ultrasound guided core needle biopsy
your doctor will use an ultrasound probe
to locate the area of concern a hollow
needle will be inserted to remove
several cores of tissue fine needle
aspiration and core needle biopsies
involve removing small samples of fluid
or tissue using a needle however if an
area of concern detected by mammogram or
ultrasound is not accessible by a core
needle biopsy or if your physician wants
to remove the entire area a surgical
biopsy may be recommended a surgical
biopsy is done in an operating room
using two techniques excisional biopsy
and incisional biopsy during an exonym
biopsy your surgeon will make an
incision in the breast and remove the
entire mass at the end of the procedure
the incision will be closed
your surgeon will perform an incisional
biopsy if only a small part of the area
of concern needs to be removed usually
to make a diagnosis at the end of the
procedure the incision will be closed
if the abnormality cannot be felt
needle localization will be used to mark
the location of the area of concern
during this procedure your radiologist
will insert a hook wire into the breast
through a needle under mammogram or
ultrasound guidance in order to mark the
area the needle will be removed but the
wire will stay in place you will then go
to the operating room where your surgeon
will make an incision in the breast he
or she will follow the wire to locate
the targeted area then remove it an
x-ray will be taken of your breast to
make sure the targeted area has been
removed then your surgeon will close the
incision